the cops are white supremacists
hell-bent on slaughtering
innocent black people that is why
only the cops should have guns that is
the argument that we are being told
right now from the left and the
narratives on systemic racism and
on gun violence are collapsing as blm
and joe biden are doubling down on both
i'm michael knowles this is the michael
knowles show
welcome back my favorite comment
yesterday from jessica lindstrom
who says two ads for harry's razors
popped up while i was watching the show
i find it ironic as well that the second
time was after michael mentioned it
maybe it wasn't ironic maybe it was
coincidental
maybe it was intentional maybe harry's
is upset
that they're suffering right now because
harry's thought that they could get away
with
insulting our audience and calling us
inexcusable
and vile and condemnable and all sorts
of things and they thought there would
be no problem with that and i'm still
being cc'd on the emails
that you guys are sending into harry's
cancelling your product so maybe they're
saying gosh maybe secretly we should
start advertising on that show again
because if harry's is running ads that
you're seeing
on my show and they're pretending that
they're not that is even more pitiful
i'll tell you what
i know that they want our money they
don't want our
any association with us but they do want
our money i probably won't give it to
them
you know i would prefer to give my money
to good companies
that will help me be prepared and take
care of my family that's why i love
ready wise ready wise it makes it so
easy to be prepared now is a better time
than ever to get ready with
long-term nutritional food options
ready-wise has emergency meals
freeze-dried fruits and vegetables for
convenient on-the-go nutrition
and new adventure meals for hiking
camping and other outdoor activities now
you know i don't really that's not
that last part's not really my cup of
tea but keeping my family prepared that
is my cup of tea
i want to keep sweet little elisa i want
to keep cute little june ready in case
there's an emergency and let me tell you
something if
the last year and a half has not taught
you that you you should be prepared i
don't know what will
ready wise makes it super easy the
quality of the food is really top-notch
but also you can prepare the meals with
just a little bit of water in some cases
you can you can put the water just right
in the pouch so you don't even need
additional supplies the water doesn't
even need to be hot
this week my listeners can get 10 off at
readywise.com when entering knowles 10
at checkout or by calling 855 453 2945
ready wise has a 30 day no questions
asked return policy there's no risk in
taking the initiative to get you and
your family prepared today that is
readywise r-e-a-d-y-w-i-s-e dot com
promo code knowles 10
to get 10 off
joe biden is taking serious action on
guns does that mean he's going to work
through the legislature to pass gun
control laws no
does that mean he's going to get a
constitutional amendment passed to
to nullify the second amendment no does
that mean he's going to go after the
guns that are involved in most of the
gun deaths in the country
no but he is really upset
about the neck brace on ar pistols
we want to treat pistols modified with
stabilizing braces
with the seriousness they deserve a
stabilizing brace hook and a pencil
essentially
makes that pistol a hell of a lot more
accurate and a mini rifle
as a result it's more lethal effectively
turning into a short barreled rifle
that's what the alleged shooter in
boulder appears to have done
it does not make the gun more lethal
that this is just pure ignorance here
the brace
does not alter the rate of fire of the
pistol it does not change the velocity
of the bullet that is fired from the
pistol
it i suppose can help you to aim perhaps
a little bit better but really it's just
going to be your
it'll it can maybe steady the gun a
little bit but it's really going to be
your aim it's going to be your facility
with shooting that that's going to
determine how accurate you are there's
an irony here
which is that one of the reasons that
pistol braces came to be in the first
place
is to allow people with disabilities to
shoot and hold a rifle with
one hand so really all joe biden is
accomplishing here
is uh is promoting ableism
among a basic constitutional right the
the second amendment right to keep and
bear arms
this is obviously a half-hearted effort
it's it's irritating people on the left
it's irritating people on the right it
doesn't seem to be making people
happy it's like he's going through the
motions we need to be tough on guns why
i couldn't tell you what's this going to
accomplish
absolutely nothing joe biden doesn't
even know the name of the agency
that that regulates firearms
what's the name of the agency you all
know three of my favorite things
alcohol tobacco and firearms atf
joe biden he like a lot of things in his
head
he got that one a little bit jumbled
today
i'm proud to nominate david chipman
to serve as the director of the aft
david knows aft well
congratulations david i'm glad that you
will be running the aft
that's great but who's running the atf i
don't know joe biden doesn't know either
and it just doesn't really matter
this is part of of joe biden's
endemic dishonesty joe biden
he because he's just an empty suit who
wakes up in the morning and licks his
finger and
tries to figure out which way the wind
is blowing he
says at one point i support the second
amendment come on man come on me and my
dad i support the second amendment man
me and corn pop do but we need common
sense gun control the pistol grip or
whatever the the
neck brace just kind of random cause
cosmetic changes really what the left is
saying here a coherent left-wing
argument is
that the second amendment is wrong
it's bad it's bad for society it was a
mistake we should get rid of it
people shouldn't have guns it's insane
that we americans have guns we're going
to get rid of them
i don't agree with that argument but at
least there is a certain coherence to it
but biden doesn't want to make that
argument because he knows that people
like their guns
and so he's going to make this squishy
half of one argument half of the other
and it also doesn't jive with the
argument we're being told by blm and by
the left broadly which supports blm
namely that cops are vicious monsters
that they're racists and skinheads and
neo-nazis
and they hate black people so what then
why on earth should civilians not be
able to protect themselves
this is what we're hearing in the george
floyd case the trial of derek chauvin
but the george floyd
case is really not going particularly
well for the prosecution
the way you can tell it's in the
language it's always in the language
that you see these subtle shifts
what have we been told why is derek
chovin going to go to jail
why does the prosecution believe that
this guy should be convicted of murder
because he put his knee on george
floyd's neck
until george floyd couldn't breathe
anymore and then he died
that's the whole argument and they're
saying forget about the high doses of
fentanyl in his body
forget about floyd resisting arrest
forget about his priors forget about all
this this was police brutality because
chauvin obstructed his airway and he had
the knee on the neck for nine minutes
except that now the prosecution is
changing its language
they're no longer talking about george
floyd's neck
they're talking about his quote neck
area
neck what's a neck area it's my neck
and it's my shoulders and it's my back
well that's different if you have the
knee on the back
that's that's very different than having
a knee on the neck so you can't breathe
at all you're totally cutting off your
windpipe
well the whole argument of course is
that derek shoving shouldn't have had
the knee on the neck
but then they ran into another problem
here which is a use of force officer
who is testifying admitted that
chauvin's procedure the use of body
weight and pressure
was a lesser use of force than would
have been adopted in the past
or that chauvin could have used himself
so it wasn't the most extreme
beyond extreme beyond the pale it was
actually a lesser use of force
now did he apply it properly that's what
they're trying to figure out now
but in terms of the knee the knee on the
neck area technique
what we're hearing even this is coming
out of the prosecution asking these
questions
is that this was relatively lesser
force but that's that's not what this
trial is going to hinge on
everyone in america everyone in the
whole wide world had heard of the
details of this case
and right now this trial is being
conducted under the threat of terrorism
we're being told by members of blm
that if chauvin is not convicted
specifically of murder
then blm is going to burn the city down
again they'll probably burn
a lot of the country down again just
like they did for months and months and
months
with absolutely no repercussions in
2020.
so how is how is justice ever going to
carry the day
if in this trial you've got the explicit
threat of terrorism
isn't that a little weird if this were
the trial of i don't know trial of
bill clinton bill clinton is it's the
impeachment trial of bill clinton
for perjury and the republicans say okay
we're gonna
we're gonna watch over this trial and we
want you to pursue justice and follow
the facts
but if you do not remove clinton from
office we're gonna burn the whole
country down again
and what if the republicans had the
credibility to say that because they had
just spent the past eight months burning
the country down
previously for the same thing do you
think
if the tables returned here that anyone
would think that that could possibly be
a fair trial
a fair carriage of justice i don't think
so
but this racial demagoguery does not
have very much logic to it
just the way it is i mean i'm almost
sick of saying if the roles were
reversed
well you know if it i mean i mention it
briefly just to show the craziness of it
but i don't think that that is a winning
argument i don't think they care i don't
think there's any logic to it
and i think conservatives should stop
pretending that it does eric bolling
the commentator and host he
had a great response on this
eric bowling was being subjected to
preposterous
illogical racial demagoguery on the bbc
so he walked off
walked off the set i think it's really
rich for any republican especially a
white man
to run around and claim that they care
about the economic condition of black
communities
and black businesses when that's all a
lie okay there's nothing in their
policies
that they've done
administration never have but what i am
is a black person in america
and everything that these voting laws
stand for
and what they look like are reminiscent
to the jim crow policies
that my family's lived under this every
single thing about it so this is all
about racial discrimination
and how dare you try to act like you are
somehow a proponent of black people and
businesses
um just to make a point and to try to
create a wedge
it's ignorant and it's just
disrespectful that's disgusting i'm done
put me off that's disgusting i am i am
nowhere
anything you're painting me to be and
the problem with american politics
is exactly that because i'm white you
think i'm racist that's
bs i'm done will you just eric will you
just stay for this question
i like that he walked off the set i'm
glad that he walked off the set
there is a certain strain on the right
that says well no you should never walk
off you should always engage in debate
or the free marketplace of ideas is
always going to be totally fair and
the good ideas will always defeat the
bad ideas not this idea
i broadly speaking agree with i'd like
to take on
bad ideas head on and i like to debate
these things but they have to be in good
faith
this woman is not acting in good faith
this is why by the way when we're
talking about things like critical race
theory
we need to go further than don't mandate
it don't require it we'll get multiple
points of view
no you need to ban that stuff you need
to ban critical race theory
because it undermines education
what this woman is saying is how dare
you you're not allowed to have an
opinion on this why because of your race
that is not a good you can't have a good
faith debate in that way
because it's pure demagoguery you're you
are undermining the premise
of the debate you're undermining
people's faith in objective truth and in
reason that's what critical
racial critical race theory does it
undermines people's
faith in reason and objective truth it
denies those things and so
we need to kick them out of the
classroom because that would be an idea
that would undermine
all of the other ideas sometimes you've
got to shut bad
things down and and you are under no
obligation and you should not
actually engage in bad faith
debate you know
one great way to in these crazy
tumultuous times to feel like you're
just
tied into something real substantial
real physical
would be to invest in physical gold
that's why i would strongly recommend
acre gold acre is this great way to
invest in physical gold when you don't
have to come out of pocket all at once
how does this work
for as low as 30 bucks a month you can
subscribe to their physical gold bars
but michael gold costs more than 30 it
does
but unless you're going to find a lot of
money in the couch cushions it's a great
way to start investing in physical gold
when your gold stash reaches the price
of their gold bars they will discreetly
ship you acre gold
right to your door they've got a new
hundred dollar a month subscription to a
five gram gold bar
they also have amid our nationwide ammo
shortage
they have a solid gold uh 24 carat nine
millimeter bullet
i wouldn't recommend shooting this out
of a gun right especially these days
with all the policies but also unless
you're killing a werewolf it's probably
not a good use of the gold bullet but
it's super duper cool it's great
visit get acre gold dot com slash
michael start investing in physical gold
today make sure you go to this url
because acre is giving away a gold bar
to qualify for the giveaway tweet or
post why you should be the recipient
and mention at get underscore acre
that's getacregold.com
michael thank you aker gold for
supporting the show
this is a record month
record month record week record year i
guess
but not the good kind of record u.s
customs and border protection
are reporting a record number number of
illegal immigrants
taken into custody at the u.s mexico
border
wow isn't that great compassion humanity
not like not like that mean old trump
no we got records records of illegal
alien children
pouring across the border the situation
has gotten so bad
that even lindsey graham who has
traditionally been pretty squishy on the
immigration question they call him
lindsey grahamnesty lindsey gramnusty
has become lindsey grambo again grambo
baby
getting tough getting real hardcore
lindsey graham calling
for a total shutdown of the immigration
system
until to paraphrase former president
trump we figure out what the hell is
going on
there was a time that we basically shut
down
travel into the united states from china
and other places
i think it's now to shut down the
immigration system and have a time out
what they've done by allevia by
abolishing the romanian mexico policy
where you no longer have to wait in
mexico to get an asylum court date
people are released into the interior of
the united states there'll be two
million people hit our border by the end
of the year at this rate
unaccompanied minors are not repatriated
back to their home country
you no longer have to apply for asylum
in your home country you no longer have
to wait in mexico
we don't deport people anymore we've had
a moratorium on deportations
the bottom line is we send every signal
to central america and the rest of the
world come here
terrorists are coming across the
suspected terrorists are coming across
the border
the bottom line is it is a completely
out of control situation
we need to shut down the immigration
system and have a time
out got to shut down this kind of travel
we've got to figure out what is going on
i i really like that lindsey ram is
saying this right now
because a complete and total shutdown of
the immigration system to me
seems draconian in the ordinary
proceeding of things
i would drastically do well one i would
stop illegal immigration
and then i would dramatically reduce
illegal immigration as well
but i i to me it just seems too radical
to say we're going to completely shut it
down
unless the the effective policy
is completely radical in the other
direction right now we effectively do
not have national borders in this
country
we've barely had national borders for a
long time and even that is collapsing
so in that world i'm much more
comfortable advocating
for a total temporary shutdown of our
immigration system
is this a change of heart is this a
change in principle for lindsey graham
or anyone else who agrees with him
no because politics is not just
abstract principles floating around in
outer space where you hold one opinion
and it's totally abstracted and you hold
that for your entire life
politics involves taking print broad
principles taking
a deep understanding of the world and
applying it to specific circumstances
so if you had asked this question
actually even i don't know five ten
years ago
said should we have a total shutdown of
our immigration system i'd say no that's
very very radical
but now today when you have the
president of the united states flouting
the law
when you've got a major party in the
united states calling for
practically open borders when you have
floods and floods and floods of foreign
nationals pouring over
kids getting literally flung over the
border
and the president saying surge come
then yes then you need to start talking
about more radical solutions
and so i'm glad to see this from lindsey
graham i hope this spreads throughout
the party you're seeing a huge
polarization here
even the traditionally more squishy
republicans like ram
moving more to the right new york city
new york state
moving more to the left new york is not
proposing a shutdown of the immigration
system on the contrary
new york is planning on giving illegal
aliens
foreign nationals living in our country
in contravention of the law
a grant of fifteen thousand six hundred
dollars
i'm not joking this it sounds like a
babylon b
headline but it's not new york will
offer quote
one-time payments of up to fifteen
thousand six hundred dollars
to undocumented immigrants who lost work
during the pandemic
according to reports that total fund is
going to come in at 2.1
billion dollars this as
americans are losing their businesses
losing their life savings losing their
livelihoods
depression suicidality up through the
roof among americans
we're going to give away five figures to
foreign nationals flouting our laws you
can't make it up
by the way this term it's being reported
as undocumented immigrants i was
watching
punitively conservative cable news today
and they used they were using the word
undocumented immigrants are
conservatives using this term now
an undocumented immigrant i was
undocumented
when i had a job when i was a teenager
because i was working off the books
that's not what that's not what we're
talking about we're talking about
foreign nationals
who are citizens of another country
living in our
country and accessing our services
illegally
that is not just being undocumented it
it
pains me to see conservatives adopting
this kind of language
it's not even so much about the money
it's the normalization of this thing
that we're gonna this is
national suicide we're gonna we're gonna
reward people
who break our laws we're gonna go real
nice and easy on blm and give them
whatever they want we're gonna pay
five figures to illegal aliens for
breaking our laws
and then we're going to imprison regular
americans in their own homes we're not
going to let them go out to work or to
see people or go to church
we're going to punish americans who
defend the american way of life
and we're going to reward people who try
to undermine the american way of life
because there is a major political
movement in this country
that has a purely negative purpose to
destroy our traditional standards in our
traditional way of life
which happens to be the subject of my
upcoming book speechless controlling
words controlling minds which you can
pre-order right now
you know turning back away from these
ridiculous policies in new york
to economic policies that are good and
work
here's a story that i promise you you
did not see
in any mainstream outlet
turns out that joe biden's
commerce secretary thinks that joe that
donald trump's economic policies were
pretty good
so this was a little just a little bit
with
commerce secretary gina raimondo during
an
interview on msnbc and it's really not
getting a lot of play in the mainstream
media
raimondo says the data show that those
tariffs have been effective what
president biden has said is there will
be a whole of government review of all
these policies and decide what it makes
sense to maintain
this is gonna this story this is why no
one's covering it the story is going to
irritate
the leftists because they don't want to
hear that trump's economic policies were
good
but it's also going to irritate the
libertarian types on the conservative
side
because they hate tariffs that was one
of their least favorite things about
trump
is that donald trump endorsed the use of
tariffs now never mind of course that
tariffs have a long-standing role in the
republican party the republican party in
many ways was founded on tariffs
abraham lincoln said give me a tariff
i'll give you the greatest nation on
earth
and there was plenty of protectionist
economic policy throughout most of our
history until really the late 20th
century
but the the conservative movement and
certainly the republican party for
at least you know three four decades at
the end of the 20th century
embraced this total free market econo
neoliberal economics
and uh but so donald trump questioned
some of that went back to an older way
of conservative thinking
and now even even joe biden's commerce
secretary has to admit
that it worked this is oh man is that
going to infuriate people but the biden
administration
i'm sure she's going to get a chewing
out for this because they're trying
even when the trump policies are so good
that they can't resist
implementing them they are
trying to pretend
like they're not following through on
these policies so a great example trump
wanted to build the wall he didn't
really succeed at building
the whole wall but he built some of the
wall and there was money allocated to
build the wall
joe biden said we're going to stop
building the wall but now it looks like
actually they might
use some of that money to keep building
the wall in certain places because they
have this
historic surge in crisis at the border
and jen saki doesn't want to admit it
she
dances around the question of walls in
in a an acrobatic way
well um wall construction remains paused
there is a review uh in underway um
taking a look at
the funds that had been allocated
when the administration took office as
you know but funds had been diverted
from military construction projects and
other purposes toward building the wall
uh that was not something we of course
uh supported
there are some components of the wall
that had already been allocated the
funding
uh to continue building by congress so
we're working
uh within what is allowable uh but our
focus is not we don't believe the wall
is an answer we have never believed the
wall is an answer to addressing
the challenges immigration challenges uh
at the border
that's why we're proposing an investment
in smart
investments in smart security at the
border why we're driving
20 what we see is 21st century solutions
for border management
and why we believe we should build a
functioning immigration system there's a
review underway of kind of where this
funding had been allocated and not
but it's currently paused and for the
most part
uh what what was that did anyone
here's what here's what i got out of
that walls are bad trump bad hate
trump's wall yeah we're spending some
money on building the wall i mean yeah
we're doing it right now but
we but it's bad and we hate it and we're
gonna build a system that that is
functioning
okay so you're admitting that you're
tacitly admitting that trump's program
is working
but you say no we we want a system that
is functioning
i talked about this last night i had my
first campus lecture back again
since covet lockdowns shut down 20
schools
which is for something to function
you need to know what it's for right
this drives me the craziest when you
have people like dr fauci say
look i don't i'm not dictating people's
politics i just dictate
policy according to what works i'm
look i'm not an idiolog i just am
talking about
what works well
what are you trying to achieve you can't
know what works unless you know what you
are working
toward but because the democrats
have outsourced their political debate
away from the people toward the experts
namely themselves they say yeah it's
going to be functioning well what is
functioning to them to me
a functioning immigration system is an
immigration system that keeps foreigners
out
it keeps people who shouldn't be in out
but to them a functioning immigration
system is when there's no wall
it's open borders and they get a bunch
of new prospective
voters that doesn't really function to
me but you know what functions very well
for a great cause relief band
relief band is the number one fda
cleared anti-nausea wristband
that has been clinically proven to
quickly relieve and effectively prevent
nausea and vomiting
associated with motion sickness anxiety
migraines
hangovers may have had one or two of
those morning sickness chemotherapy and
much
much more the product is 100 drug free
this is important for me i actually
don't like taking a lot of drugs all the
time for me it's like a little bit of
ibuprofen is about as hard as i go
this is 100 drug-free non-drowsy
provides all-natural long-lasting relief
with
zero side effects for as long as needed
the technology was originally developed
over 20 years ago in hospitals to
relieve nausea from patients
now through relief band it is available
to all of us the masses
uh it's really amazing how it works
there's a lot of imitators out there
that are really cheap
those are are not the real deal you want
the number one fda cleared anti-nausea
wristband
as the world opens back up do not let
the fear of nausea keep you on the
sidelines right now relief band has an
exclusive offer
just for our listeners go to
reliefband.com
use promo code nulls you'll get 20 off
free shipping
no questions asked 30-day money-back
guarantee what more could you ask for
that's r-e-l-i-e-f-b-a-n-d
dot com use promo code knowles for 20
off plus
free shipping joe biden is tacitly
admitting that donald trump got a lot of
things right
but just so that people don't accuse me
of being a hack just so people don't
accuse me of carrying water for the
former president there is one issue and
i've been
totally consistent on this from the
beginning but i feel president trump got
wrong
and i think the republican party is
starting to correct course on that and
that was with his
obsession with freeing criminals from
prison i just i always felt this was the
wrong idea
i felt it was the wrong messaging it was
based on a lot of phony narratives
about you know poor innocent people who
got pinched on carrying a dime bag of
pot or something
and spent their life in prison and
that's just really isn't happening right
now
so the the line you hear a lot
even from some conservatives especially
the more squishy ones on the right
they'll say we we have an
over-incarceration problem in america
and senator tom cotton made a great
point the other day
he he was asked about this issue of the
prison population and he said
actually we have a massive
under-incarceration problem in america
and he's right
what do i mean by that just
last year homicides rose 33
in major cities
clearly we are not throwing enough
people in prison at least in prison
last year a an organized
violent leftist terror organization
called
blm in partnership with another leftist
terror organization called antifa
burned down the country how many of
those
people went to prison how many of those
organizations were busted up by the feds
not none the organizations are fine i
guess some people got in trouble
but clearly not enough they feel
emboldened to commit more crimes
that's because we have an under
incarceration problem
and i know i get it the political
argument
for the jailbreak bill was well you know
we're going to appeal to black voters
this way that was the
explicit appeal that people were making
if we spring
criminals from the can that'll get black
voters to like us and i felt actually
felt it was a sort of offensive argument
to be making from the beginning
and i felt it it wasn't worth it and i
didn't think it was going to work
then there was the moral argument people
were making oh it's wrong that people go
to prison for carrying a dime bag of pot
first of all that doesn't happen
a lot of these guys have a ton of priors
or they're dealing drugs they're
pushing poison to kids they're involved
in lots of other crimes they plead these
things down
why ca i get that conservatives want to
seem like cool guys
you know we want to just seem really
cool there was that strain for a while
especially of the you do you hey
whatever you want man just don't make me
pay conservatism
which like they they wanted to be i was
like steve buscemi with the skateboard
how do you do
fellow cool guys but that that i thought
was always kind of weak
and i think that the moral arguments
that people are making are just kind of
based on
faulty faulty premises it is
not compassionate to the victims of
crimes
uh to let these guys go scot-free it is
not compassionate
to people who live in bad neighborhoods
to let criminals run those neighborhoods
it's not just
it's not right it doesn't advance racial
justice it doesn't advance any other
kind of justice
put the criminals in prison and
hopefully you can reform them by the way
i also think that we don't do a good
enough job bringing people back into
society so that's something to work on
too
but you gotta punish people for their
crimes
especially at the very least when
they're repeat repeat repeat offenders
that is a major under under
incarceration problem
one thing conservatives are starting to
get it right though
i i hope that maybe this show has played
some role in it maybe
some some writing that we've been doing
has played some role in it
the gop governors are getting a little
bit tougher on the vaccine passport i've
said on this show this needs to be a
line in the sand there are 27 republican
governors in this country
and so far yet by as of yesterday as of
two days ago three of them had come out
against vaccine passports and we've been
hammering and hammering and hammering a
lot of other conservatives joined the
chorus
then we got a another republican
governor now we've got
uh gop governor brad little
in idaho who is coming out to prohibit
the so-called vaccine passports
this will bring him to join florida
texas and utah
little's order comes after new york has
started pushing the other direction and
they want to start seeing these vaccine
passports
he says quote idahoans should be given
the choice to receive the vaccine we
should not violate idahoan's personal
freedoms by requiring them to receive it
vaccine passports create different
classes of citizens vaccine passports
restrict the free flow of commerce
during a time when life and the economy
are returning to normal vaccine
passports
threaten individual freedom and patient
privacy i really like this
you know terence williams their comedian
a friend of mine
terence tweeted the other day he said
you know look i'm not going to get the
vaccine but it's not because of politics
i just don't want to grow a tail and a
third eye
this is basically saying i'm a little
skeptical of this vaccine look vaccine
seems to be working out just fine but
hey for me i'd rather not get it it
seems like it came out very quickly and
i'm young i'm healthy i don't really
want to get it and according to the
democrat governors
terence is basically a mass murderer for
saying that and he'll probably be kicked
off social media because you're not
allowed to make any jokes about the
vaccine
if i talk about how you know all my
friends who got the vaccine are now my
personal wi-fi hotspots
their 5g flowing all through their
bodies if i make that joke i could be
kicked off of social media
and what the governors now are saying is
no that's a bridge too far
giving not just the government but big
tech and allegedly private businesses
the right to force you to inject
yourself with a very new vaccine
and then give them the right to force
you to show them your medical history
and give that medical history to big
tech companies it's a step too far
so here again i mean this looks pretty
good in idaho but we've got to keep the
feet to the fire here this cannot just
be about
the government coming out and saying
we're not going to mandate it it's
actually got to go further
it's got to say the companies can't
mandate it either we're going to
interfere in the allegedly free market
of the allegedly private businesses
to protect the constitutional rights and
the liberty
and the political traditions of
americans
that's what they have to do things are
moving in the right direction and that's
really great stuff
speaking of political dissidence and
imprisonment
this is a international story that's
also not getting a ton of news in the
west
alexei navalny is the major dissident
the sort of opposition leader in russia
to putin's regime
and it would appear that the kremlin is
killing him right now
so the kremlin tried to poison him once
and they failed and
he caught it in time and was taken to a
facility in germany he was in a coma but
he recovered
and putin said if you come back to
russia i'm going to imprison you
and navalny said well i'm going to i'm
going to do it anyway
and he flew back there and what did they
do putin imprisoned him and now it looks
like his health is failing quickly
the the guards in the prison are are
reportedly depriving him of sleep
the facility is apparently quite
unsanitary there's a tuberculosis
outbreak here
he's apparently losing quite quite a bit
of his health
and the i guess you would call this a
slow-motion assassination right they're
just going to let him
let this guy die in prison i mention
this
as vladimir putin effectively names
himself president for life
he now now according to a new law he
signed
could be in power until 2036 that would
make him 93 years old at that point
the reason i mention this is not even to
talk about the internal politics of
russia about which i know very little
and frankly about which i don't care all
that much
i do this to show political courage
alexei navalny
is went back to russia knowing he would
die
knowing that he would die for his
political cause that putin would kill
him
eventually he'd be successful and that
would be it
and we here in the united states are
neurotic over the sniffles and we're not
willing to risk really much of anything
we're not even really willing to talk up
at work about our defense of basic
american
values and waving the american flag and
i think it's very hard for us to
understand
alexi why would you do why would you go
back to russia why would you go we'll
leave germany and go back to a place
where you know this guy's going to kill
you
because there were things that matter
more than just breathing for a few more
years
we used to know that in america and now
the godless ruskies are the ones that
have to
tell this to us i don't know if they're
godless over there actually right now
there's a flourishing of religion in
russia
after after communism that's a lesson we
could learn from that is a lesson
regardless of the actual political views
of
putin and navalny that's a lesson we can
learn
turns turns out there are things in life
worth
dying for all right we've got to get to
the mailbag first though
you know there's going to be a great
episode out of candace today i don't
know what she's talking about you know
who the other guests are but i'll tell
you there's one guest on that show oh
gosh you were going to want to see him
handsome
articulate oh a mellifluous voice
so definitely go and check out candace
a absolutely great show 9 pm eastern 8
pm central
at dailywire.com you can also check out
the podcast audio version of that
which is under candace be sure to leave
a 5 star review we'll be right back
with the mailbag
welcome back to the mailbag my favorite
time of the week first question from
dennis
dennis says so i was watching the bible
on easter
you're going to wait for it to jump up
and down how are you watching them but
you mean you're reading the bible
i don't know when jesus was on the cross
and speaking to god
the roman soldiers seemed to almost look
like they felt bad for what they did
do you think the roman soldiers thought
they had messed up for doing what they
did
or do you think they still wrote him off
as a heretic like the jewish high priest
did like caiaphas did
no i don't i don't think they had any
particular
interest in these religious views i do
know that pontius pilate was very
disconcerted by jesus and his and
pontius pilate's wife suffered
nightmares because of jesus and
pilate has this very famous moment
where he's talk he's saying what are you
doing why aren't you standing up for
yourself why
and jesus you know just
says that he is the truth and and pilate
the cynic says
what is the truth what is truth and
washes his hands of the matter but
pilate was was troubled
he was a fairly sophisticated guy and he
was troubled by christ
and the the romans did take pity on him
they offered him
effectively a gall but what was
effectively a sort of drug that would
that would numb the pain a little bit
and he turns it away at the beginning of
the crucifixion and then after it is
accomplished he
he takes it but doesn't doesn't have
very much of it
so did they they feel bad well what were
they i mean
their job is to execute criminals their
job is to follow the law
and christ was condemned through this
legal process
and even you know caiaphas and the high
priests
part of their enmity against christ was
their
envy of him he threatened their power
just as people awaiting the the jewish
messiah felt that
that that messiah would threaten roman
power and political stability
but ultimately these are all people
when when we have the passion narrative
when we're going through
the passion of christ when members of
the congregation
participate in that we are the ones who
yell crucify him crucify him
that is that is our role in this and we
because we are we are the cause of this
and really it's not just about pilate
it's not just about
judas and it's not just about caiaphas
and it's not just about the roman
soldiers and it's not it's about sin
it's about the consequence of sin that
will either lead to the death and
enslavement of mankind
or will lead to this redemption
which is why on easter christians sing
o happy fault the fall of of adam in the
garden
oh happy fault that won for us so great
so gloria is a redeemer
from matthew hey michael how quickly
will the audiobook for speechless be
made available your audiobook version of
reasons to vote for democrats was
fantastic
by the way speechless comes out on my
wife's birthday and i need a gift hmm
i think it makes a great gift thank you
i'm glad you listened to the audiobook
of reasons to vote for democrats uh the
john cage estate was a little upset with
me but i think it's a good one
we will be recording the audiobook for
speechless that's going to be coming up
i think i'm going to be recording that
within a few weeks
the the book itself goes to the printer
on i think
april 15th or something like that i mean
that's going to be going out within days
and then it's done and i don't need to
make any more edits and i will then read
it for the audio book and then that will
go up i appreciate people pre-ordering
it
it's done quite well on the the
pre-order charts
so we'll see how long it is able to
remain on amazon you can also
get an autographed first edition over at
premiere collectibles so if you're
interested in that sort of thing head on
over
and thank you for for doing that next up
from
nick hi michael huge fan of the show i
watched your guest appearance on c-span
today and i wanted to ask a question
regarding the role of religion in our
government
the declaration of independence
explicitly mentions three unalienable
rights life
liberty and the pursuit of happiness how
did the founding fathers arrive at these
specific rights and why are they the
most important from a christian
perspective thank you so much
well there are some great parallels here
between the declaration of independence
and john locke who describes the rights
to life liberty
and and property uh and so where does
john locke get it from well
locke like liberal thinkers
enlightenment thinkers
gets this from the western tradition and
where that comes from ult
ultimately really is the catholic church
and in particular
the way that the catholic church
synthesizes this revelation of christ
and you and the the old testament
and the uh pre-christian greeks the
pagan philosophers
and so you know it's all ultimately
coming from from there
now why these three rights well it makes
a lot of sense
our pursuit of happiness uh is
how we would describe you know the sort
of
end of our civil society right i mean
justice is the end of civil society as
madison says and we are pursuing
flourishing happiness in society
you can't do that without liberty and
you can't have liberty without life
this is why very important to remember
life is not just
one issue among many now like well you
know we can talk about
life or we can talk about drug policy or
we can talk about taxes
it's not just one among our immigration
life is
the prerequisite for all of these other
rights
that is a catholic point of view and
it's one that our present
catholic president is is disregarding
but we we know this just naturally we
know that life is the prerequisite for
all of these
so you you ought to focus on those three
and you got to focus on them in that
order
from theodore dear michael according to
dan bongino
he said most republicans are really
democrats but no democrats are really
republicans
that's a great point dan always has
these really good pithy points
what are you saying i mean look at asa
hutchinson he's a great example asa
hutchinson the governor of arkansas who
i thought i thought he was sort of
conservative i guess not
he vetoes a bill that says that
the perverts are not allowed to pump
little kids full of hormones to make
johnny look like jane
right so he vetoes that bill and when
asked why he says well
you know that's just part of the culture
wars and we need to focus on things that
really matter you know like whatever
corporate tax policy
or something and you think oh
so what you're really saying is that's
part of the culture war you totally
concede the culture war to the left
you are perfectly happy living in the
left's world as long as you can make a
little bit more money or something like
that
well that means you're really a democrat
it just means you're a greedy democrat
you know there's sometimes and i look
i've done this myself okay
back in my wayward youth i would have
called myself a fiscal conservative
social liberal and what i really would
have meant by that is i'm a fiscal
libertarian and a social
degenerate a derelict what that means
though when you say that is
that you are a greedy democrat right you
support
the democrats policies but you want to
keep more of of your own money
okay you know that's a good step on the
road to becoming a conservative
but that's not a sustainable argument so
i think that's what dan is really
getting at
and you don't really see that on the
democrat side a little bit here and
there
they kind of clinton types but really
they tend to be
true believers maybe you got a mansion
or something like that but
really they tend to be on the left next
question from michael
hi michael i wanted your opinion on the
catholic church's china virus stance
my local diocese was saying that they do
not condone testing vaccines on cells of
aborted babies but as an act of charity
and to prevent more suffering we can get
the vaccine
to me this seems like a slippery slope
cancer causes suffering but does that
mean we should condone euthanasia
love the show thank you very much well i
guess the argument that the bishops are
making
in allowing people or saying it's
permissible to
to use a vaccine that was
made developed through certain
cells from certain lines derived from
aborted babies decades ago
is that this is a a relatively remote
cooperation with evil
and we engage in similarly remote
cooperations with evil every day when i
go to starbucks and i buy a coffee
starbucks matches employee donations to
charities
one charity that employees can choose to
have money donated to
is planned parenthood so when i buy
starbucks am i giving money to planned
parenthood in a remote way i suppose i
am but at a certain point we wouldn't be
able to interact at all in society if if
we
had such a wide threshold for that sort
of thing
now i think the vaccines are a little
different i mean you're using
dead babies to to make your inoculation
against the wu flu i i don't know that
that
that seems to me graver but the bishops
have
have given their guidance on this and i
suppose that's above my pay grade
but i do think there is a little bit of
a fear of a slippery slope argument here
i don't think it's quite like the same
as saying
we're going to start committing
euthanasia you know we're going to start
killing people
if they if they don't feel good one day
but it's
uh yeah i don't think it's the sort of
thing that ought to be encouraged
katie right hey michael i really
appreciate what you've been saying
lately about denying money and business
to corporations that vocally disdain
conservatives and choose to go woke
i wish i could do this when it comes to
seemingly monopolized airlines i travel
regularly and have been loyal to
particular airlines for their quality
and prices
you can just say it's delta right you
talk about delta because they have high
quality the prices aren't that great but
they're okay
but with everything from aggressive mass
rules in early 2020 to their recent
political behavior regarding voting
regulations i'm loathe to keep giving
them my business
do you foresee any alternatives for air
travel in the future where can i sign up
for air daily wire frequent flyer
program oh man if only how great would
that be
um and you know if then we're flying you
just get there so much faster
and that somehow the announcements would
be even you know normally the airline
announcements are uh well
uh so uh we're about to
uh touch down but if it were better i
would be like uh guys the idea that
we're gonna get here
in six hours is apparently ridiculous
we're gonna get there in four hours uh
uh
so that would be great but the short
answer your question is
the airlines are a little bit of a
racket they are
highly regular regulated it's hard for
new players to break into the market
and therefore withholding our money
is not probably going to be enough
what you're going to need to do is not
just exercise that kind of personal
cultural power
you also need to exercise political
power when you get into positions of
political authority
you need to make it really hard for
these airlines to operate
when they try to undermine your republic
now georgia's doing this to some effect
they're denying
delta some of their tax credits
okay great they've done that before it
hasn't bankrupted delta but if you had
broader political action on this front
then maybe you could get these woe
companies to stop
stop attacking your your way of life
because it's it's not just the fringe
cultural super duper conservatives who
are saying this sort of thing it's mitch
mcconnell mitch mcconnell is his
establishment as it gets but he's saying
you can't just give these guys a blank
check and allow
corporations to set up a parallel
government that's no good that's like
the worst possible situation
so that's what i would do i would flex
political power if we can ever get it
again
and if we don't if we don't get voter
integrity back under control then who
knows if we will
next question from michael dear michael
i have noticed that msnbc cnn pbs and
other loud
champions of wokeness have many articles
calling the new virus variants after the
places where they arose
like the brazilian variant the uk
variant the south african variant
weren't we told that it was a sure sign
of racism and white supremacy to cause
cole sars kovid to
the wuhan virus did
the ministry of truth change the rules
and i missed it now here's the rule if
if the virus comes from a white-ish
place
white or white-ish place then you can
call it by its name
and if it comes from an asian place then
you can't
all right that's basically it the uk
white south africa
largely white obviously it's a complex
racial situation there but it was run by
whites for a very long time
and brazil i know they're like sort of
white right is that i don't know they're
white hispanics
i don't know what the new term i don't
keep up on all the racial lingo but
that's the new rule it's just different
rules for different races because the
left is instituting a new racial caste
system
that's the way it goes it's not
necessarily hypocrisy it's just a new
a new hierarchy i think conservatives
would prefer if we just didn't focus on
race and we didn't think that's the most
important thing about people but the
left really wants to
so they're going to set up a caste
system from unknown
this is unknown who's who is on how
mysterious
michael knowles i've heard you and ben
shapiro talking about the covid vaccine
passports a bit
i was wanting to know if you see them as
being potential hipaa violations
medical privacy that's a good point also
i want to thank you
for referring to dr rachel levine or
whatever he calls himself is he he
irritates me when even people from our
side let people like him live in his
fantasy
of being a girl when he quite obviously
isn't please keep it up i appreciate
that thank you
yeah i think this is an important point
because there's
there's increasingly a fissure on the
right between the people who
are standing up for objective truth and
are willing to assert objective truth in
the public sphere
and the people who might stand up for
objective truth in their personal life
but they don't really want to make
anyone else do that and they don't want
to assert that in the public sphere
and they think we can all just kind of
do our own thing and we won't bother
anybody
and i think increasingly the latter
vision is untenable and i think we just
we need to stand up for the truth now
we're not going to have an opportunity
to
as for the hipaa violations and kind of
the medical questions of the vaccine
passports yeah i mean that's
that is pretty it's a good line of
argument i'd be happy to make it
i think there are even broader concerns
here um
namely it's an upending of our way of
life it's an upending of our political
order it empowers a whole lot of people
who shouldn't have a lot of power
and we should simply not stand for that
sort of thing whatever the argument is
it's kind of like with big tech do you
go after big tech on fraud
or section 230 or on some other matter i
don't know just go after them just go
after them and break it up because we
cannot support that anymore i'm michael
noel's the michael knowles show
see you monday
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer
jeremy boary our technical director is
austin stevens
supervising producers mathis glover and
robert sterling
production manager pavel vadovsky editor
and associate producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coramina
hair and makeup by nika geneva and
production coordinator mckenna waters
the michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire
2021 hey everybody this is andrew clavin
host of the andrew clavin
show you know some people are depressed
because the republic is collapsing the
end of days is approaching
and the moons turn to blood but on the
andrew clavin show that's where the fun
just gets started so come on over to the
andrew clavin show and laugh your way
through the fall of the republic with me
andrew clavin